[Music]  jobber had many vessels  got a lot of ground to cover if we had  to keep his empire intact  i can make the rounds without you jabba  rarely left his chambers jabber ruled  with fear  i intend to rule with respect  if i may  speak freely  in difficult times  fear is a sure  i am not a bounty hunter  i've heard otherwise  i know that you sit on the throne of  your former employer  [Applause]  jabber ruled with fear  i intend to rule with respect  were always captains under jabba the  hutt  i'm here to make a proposal that's  mutually beneficial  [Applause]  why speak of conflict  when cooperation can make us all rich  [Music]  what prevents us all from killing you  and taking what we want  [Music]  if he had spoken such insolence to jabba  he'd have fed you to his menagerie  please  speak freely  [Music]  you